séptima jornada de protestas en Francia
contra la reforma de las pensiones del
gobierno de Manuel macron mientras el
senado tiene hasta mañana para debatir
la propuesta legislativa Tenemos reporte
desde París
el grupo de mercenarios Wagner que
lidera la ofensiva rusa en bacmut
asegura estar cerca ya del centro de la
ciudad devastada por los combates una de
las batallas más largas y mortales de la
guerra podría estar llegando a su fin
el presidente chileno Gabriel borich
cumple un año en el cargo con un
reformado gabinete ministerial y una
leve subida de la popularidad sin
embargo la falta de mayoría en el
parlamento el rechazo al plebiscito
constitucional o la alta inflación
obstaculizan el cambio prometido
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
maceu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos esta edición informativa en
Francia porque este sábado las calles
del país vuelven a ser escenario del
rechazo social a la propuesta de reforma
de pensiones del gobierno de Manuel
macron miles de personas salieron a las
calles a protestar en 200 puntos del
país solo días después de que el pasado
martes tuviera lugar la movilización más
masiva contra el proyecto entonces según
el Ministerio del interior un millón
280.000 personas participaron en las
marchas recordemos que uno de los puntos
del texto que mayor oposición genera es
el aumento de los años de trabajo
necesarios para retirarse con la pensión
completa en general la edad de
jubilación pasaría de 62 a 64 años
previamente nuestra periodista Natalia
Ruiz nos explicó En qué punto se
encuentra el debate sobre la ley en el
senado
bueno el debate en el senado continúa
los senadores están trabajando desde muy
temprano esta mañana y como ustedes
saben pues se tienen hasta la medianoche
de este domingo para terminar ya de
examinar todo este texto de ley ahora el
gobierno el día de ayer sacó otra de
esos de esos haces bajo la manga que es
un artículo en la Constitución que le
permite al gobierno digamos que sea
mucho más expedista toda esta todo este
trámite legislativo en el senado y de
aquí en adelante el senado ya no puede
ir examinando artículo por artículo ni
tampoco enmienda como por enmienda como
venía haciéndolo sino que tiene que
hacerlo sobre la totalidad del texto o
incluso sobre una parte Así que esto
pues va a ser acelerar un poco las cosas
esperando a lo que suceda ya la próxima
semana el 15 de marzo cuando va a
reunirse esa comisión paritaria de siete
diputados y siete senadores que tienen
que acordar ya una digamos una una
versión final de este texto del proyecto
de ley
en otras noticias en Ucrania avanza el
cerco de las fuerzas rusas sobre bahmud
escenario de una de las batallas más
largas y mortales de la guerra este
sábado el líder del grupo de mercenarios
Wagner publicó un video en el que dice
encontrarse cerca del centro de esta
ciudad de dunesca hoy mismo la agencia
rusa además
rían novostic hizo públicas imágenes que
revelan la devastación de la urbe Donde
antes de la guerra vivían 70.000 civiles
de los que quedan solo 4.000 según la
presidencia de Ucrania nos amplía lluís
Muñoz
un paisaje difícil de imaginar incluso
para el mejor diseñador de producción de
Hollywood en bahmud vivían 70.000
personas Ahora solo quedan escombros
carros levantados granadas sin explotar
cuerpos de ucranianos abandonados y
soldados rusos explicando cómo la
batalla se desarrolla casa a casa
Tuvimos que destruir las casas para
avanzar ocurrió con casi todas las casas
las asaltamos todas había varios grupos
en cada casa la batalla de bahamut
quedará en los libros de Historia La
filmación es de la agencia rusa
riano bosti su periodista compara esta
batalla con la de stalingrado en la
Segunda Guerra Mundial gran parte de la
ciudad ya está controlada por Rusia que
no logra conquistarla del todo
bahmud es la vía de Rusia para avanzar
hacia kramators y eslovians y así
profundizar en el don más sin embargo
los analistas no consideran que tenga
valor estratégico no es una ciudad de
guarnición ni centro de transporte ni un
importante centro de población su
importancia se ha vuelto más bien
propagandista Rusia necesita obtener Por
fin una victoria sin grandes éxitos
desde el verano y después de meses de
cruentas batallas en bahamut donde
habrían muerto entre 20.000 y 30.000
soldados rusos por su parte Ucrania ha
decidido defender hasta el final la
ciudad sus militares ven una oportunidad
de poder causar allí múltiples bajas a
sus rivales según la otan por cada
Ucrania no están muriendo cinco rusos
es difícil defender la fortaleza de
bakmuth porque muchas fuerzas enemigas
están aquí
desafortunadamente hay muchos compañeros
muriendo pero Los Tiranos mueren más
en Rusia bahamut también es una batalla
interna el grupo Wagner se atribuye los
éxitos militares su líder jeffeny
prigosin quiere demostrar que su empresa
militar es mejor que el propio ejército
y superar en su enfrentamiento al
ministro de defensa sergeygu al que
critica con frecuencia
Hoy hace exactamente tres años el 11 de
marzo de 2020 fue la primera vez que la
Organización Mundial de la Salud usó la
palabra pandemia para referirse al brote
de Kobe 19 en este tiempo la universidad
John Hopkins contabilizó seis millones
ochocientas mil muertes por coronavirus
Y ayer 10 de marzo de 2023 dejó de
actualizar el registro Rafael Pérez nos
amplía
hemos hecho la evaluación de que el Coby
19 puede caracterizarse como una
pandemia
este anuncio cambió la historia de la
humanidad comenzaba así un periodo de
crisis y medidas drásticas
todos enfrentamos una amenaza común el
coronavirus Kobe 19 la declaración de
pandemia de hoy es un llamado a la
acción para todos en todas partes
también es un llamado a la
responsabilidad y solidaridad
los confinamientos una de las medidas
para evitar la propagación convirtieron
a las principales urbes en ciudades
fantasma una calma solo rota por
muestras de Patriotismo como en Italia
una de las naciones más afectadas por la
enfermedad
bronca la muerte pero no todos en el
mundo estuvieron conformes en China la
política cero covid provocó el
descontento de la población
[Aplausos]
Al otro lado del mundo algunos
mandatarios se mostraron escépticos por
los encierros
no vamos a destruir nuestro país tenemos
que regresar porque ya sabes en cierto
punto perderás más personas de esta
manera por todos los problemas causados
que con lo que estamos haciendo
según la universidad John Hopkins hasta
el mes de marzo de 2023 se
contabilizaron unos 676 millones
609.955 casos de estos pacientes seis
millones ochocientos ochenta y un mil
novecientos cincuenta y cinco
fallecieron un cambio importante en la
estrategia de combate al virus
resultaron ser las vacunas hasta la
misma fecha se han inoculado más de
13.300 millones de personas sin embargo
a pesar de que las restricciones han
venido disminuyendo considerablemente el
covid sigue siendo considerado una
emergencia sanitaria mundial
y la bbc está en el centro de la
polémica tras suspender a su presentador
deportivo más conocido y estrella del
fútbol Gary lineker el motivo del cese
es que lineker criticó en su cuenta
personal de Twitter la propuesta
migratoria del gobierno de Richie sunak
que recordemos pretende impedir que las
personas que lleguen clandestinamente a
territorio británico puedan pedir asilo
el exfutbolista tildó la iniciativa de
horrible cruel y denotan distinta a la
de Alemania en los años 30 la bbc
Consideró que lineker rompió la línea
editorial de la corporación pública a lo
que el presentador respondió que es
libre de expresar su opinión personal la
suspensión del ineter ha generado el
rechazo de la audiencia así como una ola
de renuncias en el servicio deportivo de
la bbc además en expresión de protesta
distintos programas deportivos de la
cadena no se emitieron este sábado el
director de la bbc ha asegurado que no
va a dimitir por la polémica que ha
incluso llevado al pronunciamiento del
Primer Ministro
como Primer Ministro tengo que hacer lo
que creo que es correcto respetando que
no todo siempre estarán de acuerdo por
eso he sido inequívoco en mi enfoque
para detener los barcos Gary lineker fue
un gran futbolista y es un presentador
talentoso espero que la situación actual
entre Gary lineker y la bbc se resuelva
de manera oportuna pero es un asunto de
ellos no del gobierno vamos ahora con
información de América Latina porque en
Chile el presidente de izquierdas
Gabriel borich celebra hoy su primer año
de mandato Este primer aniversario
coincide con una reestructuración de su
gabinete de ministros y con el rechazo
del Congreso a su reforma fiscal Pero
también esta marcado por una leve subida
de la popularidad del mandatario en los
sondeos de opinión
nos hace un repaso del año del
presidente chileno
el 11 de marzo de 2022 el presidente
Gabriel borich asumió el poder en Chile
abriendo una etapa inédita la de un
mandato de cuatro años otorgado al jefe
de estado más joven de la historia del
país
Un año más tarde el balance de su
gestión se ve marcado por la baja
popularidad y una serie de tropiezos en
la semana previa la celebración del
primer año de gobierno el mandatario
sufrió un revés la cámara de diputados
rechazó su proyecto de reforma fiscal
pieza central del programa de su
gobierno preveía Un aumento progresivo
de los impuestos para los sectores más
ricos del país con el fin de financiar
nuevos derechos sociales en educación
pensiones y salud esta fue la segunda
derrota del ejecutivo chileno la primera
ocurrió el 4 de septiembre de 2022
cuando el 62% de los votantes rechazó el
proyecto de una nueva constitución el
golpe que le significó al plebiscito del
4 de septiembre sin duda tan valió
muchísimo al gobierno ha sido un
terremoto que le ha afectado tanto desde
el punto de vista de su proyecto
político que quería instalar en Chile
pero también respecto de quiénes eran
las autoridades quienes eran los voceros
que Ellos tenían al interior del
gobierno otra crisis para el gobierno
fue la del conflicto mapuche en el sur
del país donde la población indígena
reclama desde hace años la devolución de
las tierras ancestrales si bien el
presidente había criticado la
militarización de la zona por parte del
gobierno anterior dio un giro de 180
grados al anunciar el regreso de los
militares pero a pesar de todos estos
contratiempos el primer aniversario de
su mandato coincide también con signos
de recuperación económica con una caída
de la inflación el control del desempleo
y un fortalecimiento del peso frente a
las Divisas extranjeras
decimos sábado de protestas en Israel en
contra de la Reforma judicial impulsada
por el gobierno de coalición de extrema
derecha liderada por Benjamin nettanyahu
según los opositores la ley socava la
independencia de los tribunales al
subyugar la Corte Suprema al parlamento
las manifestaciones convocadas cada
sábado han ganado fuerza a medida que la
legislación se acerca a se ratificada
Incluso en una acción inédita los
reservistas del ejército se unieron a
las protestas que claman contra el
supuesto fin de la democracia en Israel
sin embargo varias organizaciones de
Derechos Humanos señalan que la
democracia israelí está en entredicho
desde que permite la ocupación ilegal de
territorios palestinos y desde que se
basa en un sistema de discriminación
y amnistía internacional han calificado
de apart
y en Siria decenas de menores que fueron
reclutados en su momento por el
autodenominado estado islámico están en
tratamientos de rehabilitación para
volver a la vida civil Max Pérez
Gallardo nos cuenta más
pateando un balón o pintando más de 50
menores buscan encontrar una nueva vida
después de ser reclutados por el estado
islámico a temprana edad expuestos a la
violencia y al extremismo ideológico
estos menores que se encuentran en el
centro de rehabilitación orquesh
experimentan las secuelas de criarse en
entornos sumamente conflictivos lo que
les provoca problemas en la
socialización y en el desarrollo
cognitivo
no queremos que los niños estén
permanentemente en estos centros pero
los esfuerzos diplomáticos son lentos
por eso pensamos que Establecer un nuevo
centro es estratégicamente mejor hoy en
día Cuando hablamos de rehabilitación de
niños no hablamos solo de 100 o 200
niños hay muchos más que necesitan
rehabilitación
los padres de algunos de ellos proceden
de países como Estados Unidos Reino
Unido o Francia y aunque por normas del
derecho internacional estas naciones
tienen responsabilidad de aceptar a los
niños dentro de sus fronteras los
trámites de retorno son obstaculizados
por controversias de política interna la
meta de este centro es trabajar con los
menores para que en un futuro puedan
volver a casa
el objetivo a largo plazo de nuestro
proyecto es preparar a los niños para
que puedan aceptar a otros e integrarse
en sus sociedades cuando sean
repatriados
el reclutamiento infantil dentro de los
conflictos armados está prohibido por la
normatividad internacional un marco
legal constantemente transgredido por
organizaciones extremistas según
Naciones Unidas los niños son reclutados
entre otras cosas con motivos
propagandísticos que generarían
visibilidad mundial Además de que la
manipulación a los menores es más
efectiva en Siria la esperanza por
devolverle su niñez a miles es latente
Muchas gracias por su atención sigan con
nosotros
[Música]